ladies and gentlemen hello
this press conference of the
president of the european commission
the dance years of reign of the president of the
european council
mr charles michel everyone will make
an intervention then we will take your
questions like he did yesterday through
our new system in the  amas
president you have the floor
hello everyone
the whole european union and many
other countries in europe and around the world
are in a form of confinement the
restrictive measures taken by
member states have been crucial to
reduce the number  new
infections
it has helped our systems to
cope but these measures have a
huge cost of 10 million people are
stuck at home too often in
small accommodation
they have to juggle
telework and family life the
shoals  of baghdad at adapt to
learn at home and are limited in
their time in their activities
the elderly are isolated to
protect them and to its general difficulties
is added a long list of
economic difficulties economic for our citizens
the shops the  restaurants the factories
they have all closed
they have lost most of their
businesses trade has
slowed down enormously all over the world
governments are using all
available means to strengthen
health systems and to support
businesses and the self-employed
all of this has a  already gigantic cost of
these actions represent in the
european union nearly 3000 billion
euros and other measures will want to
drunk as shown by the result of
the eurogroup last week in
this context the public authorities
must carefully assess the
best time to start lifting
the restriction measures one after
the other
it is a very difficult task
the countries of the european union have been
affected differently in
terms of the intensity and timing of
the pandemic  to forms d of aziz
does not exist one size fits all roads no
race to be telo but
individual projects member states marine and two
majors today we do you want is weak
rest at one which would have is not it
is not signum  of alpha manas intended to
provide frame form member states of
subjects more we recommend red hood
close had operated rugby coltine
news japanese values ​​monitors
at the bottom of bizarre things
epidemiological criterion date thing of
hardly 19 years means that in said crisis
datsyuk city tours to have
intensive 4 8000 voice capacity
nineteen peugeot 206 full and were to
you will be hot to both parties and
systems units displays a
surveillance monitoring capacity a
formula at risk and testing of spirit
company and bike recommendations
always pleasant  as solidays is one of the
coordinators access to penguins at
just because you very simple factor
the writing to do so many concerning in
libya by 2010 as date the one who
feeds eto'o ready for anything proves
with friends who tarnish thoughts
you know how to do and moreover the
styx and treatment of development of a
vaccine and you and your vaccine when we
have maxime
des diplomates vaccine and collecting
amap and innovative sappi gavi economic
response ezio our magnificent children
support system in the role  of the
massive attraction private investments
brown wildcats chief told us
investiture h rome cirad under
starcraft drowning then match of a
transparent ace der heyden soundcloud
they can be innovation mottois
investment vote without fault to
christianity and mozilla enormous
filastine of mark strong investment
sir  the president thank you even the
president
the crisis we are facing
is unprecedented
it is gigantic and the first
thoughts I want to address them to
all citizens in the world
but especially European citizens who
are directly or
indirectly affected by the virus and  I want to
salute all its citizens in all the
countries who are mobilized to
guarantee health systems that are as
efficient as possible also salute all
those who are mobilized to
maintain as much as possible a
capacity for activity at the start  of the
internal market and the transport of
essential and necessary goods
the task has been entrusted to us by the
European Council to the con of the
Commission and to myself is based on two
pillars
the idea of ​​presenting to the European Council
a roadmap which must propose a
a certain number of measures in connection with
an exit strategy these are the points
that were presented a few
moments ago by the chair of the
committee in order to have the
most coordinated approach possible when
we can gradually lift the
restrictive measures  exceptional measures
which had to be decided on the
national port throughout the last few
weeks and we are well aware that these
exceptional restriction measures
which affect life in the world but
especially life within the
European Union they directly affect
everyone's intimate  of us it is
two of the most basic personal freedoms
that have been
directly affected by these decisions
that are taken and these are obviously
potentially extraordinary repercussions
extremely heavy on the
economic level and on the social level
with which we are confronted and which
most certainly we will be confronted
throughout the next few months, perhaps
even throughout the
next few years, which is why
we are totally
convinced that the 27 member states
that it is essential thanks to these
recommendations which are
recommendations
inspired by common sense also inspired
by scientific data he
trusts that we want to address to
those who advise us in
the decision-making process
they must make it possible to ensure
that gradually
gradually we cannot in the same way
in the different  countries but
in any case in a similar way by a
common approach to ensure that there is
the capacity to implement
this sebring exit strategy this
very he carries a cup 39.2 commission
for myself is the wicker reid strategies
in auzits not with aids in turn diana
wyss from different institutions and
stay in a day to be enough to tackle 10
you challenge of cases need to fight or
dead explains jean louis mailloux punk
ans il via videoconference and ruby ​​de
force one in few  weeks in a few weeks
she admits goal is to open strategic
discussion inna de toucy aux is it
possible to day to day 2 to take some 20
82 June 6 1 to open de process hindemith
tam hindelang volume i know how to be and
of any guarantee  had words where she
is strong from uconn citizens and mixed
with the next month in next year in my
opinion or i need to tackle funds
chaptes must therefore be everything by
kostoff false webs wikio vrie
strategy of first one of cause of
signs  to mark the first point and the
internal market the internal market is
a common good for the european union
the internal market and the beating heart
of economic development and therefore of
the capacity for social cohesion for
the european union the internal market has
been  damaged it has been affected by
decisions that have been taken for
legitimate reasons for health reasons
the first
irritated and to repair the
internal market of iron in rain output are
violated appropriately
the second priority is to ensure
that we  can improve the
internal market corrected data
ensure that we can have the
capacity to strengthen this
internal market with a particular focus, in
my view, on issues relating
to industrial strategy
the commission has made
very useful proposals on this subject  without forgetting
the importance of considering the fabric the
network of small and medium-sized
European enterprises as being a
vital network for the incapacity of
well-being and for the capacity for success
of this European project and on this first
pillar of the internal market, I do not forget
not that the question of the digital agenda
and the question of liu peng green deal the
question of this climate issue
must be levers more necessary
than ever to succeed in this
economic transformation to succeed in
its ability to meet this challenge which we
as a generation are facing
of this abduction he marie opinion destroyed
nitoo 10 k swiss of calixte is developing
about fifteen there for his friends
promotes it is then it diab according to him
requires i do is developing a massive
investment strategy she wrote you
are the external mission budget he  which
eliminates in order to succeed in it also
used different all smiles final
around youtube and week ben chalbi
the essential to in order to focus on
took over this to be carried out his
straight to a jacket min strategy
in  the next month in the next year is
a mini everything remains liable from
youpine perspective can be also with
the support of all the best is to be
effective and forget it's that it's
soul and is very essentials strategy of
fact
worse  they support me in addition to
succeed in the wicker tree strategy is
not to fall est dit external
responsibility of tokyo new new new nord
est 6 e pioline a wii their story
exton
a fisherman we consider that it's in
porte faux to play offs tons  of
mussels is said international is an
honor to be thus awarded a star
for not of multilateralism
we believe that multilateralism is
an added value by on the
global challenges we face
and we have once again
painful proof of this  with this
pandemic that is hitting the world and not
just a country where a part of the world
that is hitting the world as a whole
requires global responses
that is what we do when with
the commission we propose to take
their responsibilities
in the case of the g7  as part of the g20,
for example, developing the ability
to channel
financial resources to accelerate the ability to
find d axa and
appropriate therapies as quickly as possible
is time to bring in these therapies and as
long as they are accessible for  the
whole world and not only for a
part of the world which would be privileged in
the face of this pandemic in this case
the international I will emphasize
a point which must be close to our hearts it
mobilizes us completely completely
knows the importance of a  very
strong partnership with africa and caesar for
which we have supported
european leaders together with african leaders
this call for mobilization to
further support health systems in
africa is a short and
medium term oddity
this call also have  a debate on
debts in africa how can we
lighten the debt burden that weighs on
the african continent and how can we
in the medium to long term
i want to say transform our
strategy to africa founded it  on a
partnership of equals of mutual interest
bet on
strategic investments which must be coherent
with the young gypsy or with the green
deal and finally of force volt its history
and I said beast
induyco punk and the case of  twin need to
get in my opinion view of resilience and
possible fraud having had a
license toulon perspective which fails
in my opinion don't hesitate so it's
strength to be strong after 10 prize you're
not so bolt or chamonix
so touching  piece darwich is forgotten
bolt or basic leaf we have alsace there
are certainly lessons to be learned
in terms of crisis management from
a european perspective lessons to be
learned from an ability to face
together to coordinate actions at the
start of impulse  European Unions and on these
subjects we also wish,
as the European Union is at the
rendezvous, to be up to the challenges
with which we are confronted
I will conclude by telling you that more than
ever the beating heart of the
European Union is based on the principles of
solidarity of unity of responsibility of the
capacity to carry out permanent
evaluation in order to be permanently
capable, with common sense and with a
medium and long-term vision, of ensuring
that we can offer European citizens
the most legitimate responses  the
strongest on the phone they have the right
to wait
thank you the minimums of the month a
squat close to ours meets the mic
indeed during video series griselda
pastor president sartori knicks are
caught on one leg
thank you very much and rico
hello but it's  is the president tennis
madam president I assume that you
have followed the forecasts of the
international monetary fund on the fall of
growth in the union I
would like to know what is the level
of investment which you believe is
necessary to face this
falls and growth
i would like to know what serra was
content to bring a proposal to the
table of head of government for the
council of the 24th and given the debates
of the ministers of economy whether
these new brick lane records  must
be subject to any conditions
to use this money
first of all the first point that you are
sensitive to indicate is that during the
last weeks very
important decisions have been taken with a
very significant financial impact in the
European central bank
the european bank has taken very substantial decisions
after the decision the
commission has taken and
in particular the activation of
the general escape clause and the
state aid regime which has been adapted is
what the group has decided it  a few
days ago makes it possible to mobilize more than 500
billion euros which are injected to
support economic activity
there is a point of the jury with clarity as we
speak
we can make forecasts on
the economic impact these are
forecasts which are very unstable and
uncertain uncertain and unstable because
we have to succeed in the geeks' strategy
as best as possible to limit
the negative collateral effects as much as possible
savings that we put it more
simply my opinion is that for
the moment we  do not yet know the
amount of the addition test of before
for which we owe with the states
mans with the commission and the
european central bank tried to specify
throughout the next few weeks
what is the amount of the addition there
will be  two questions I want to be
absolutely clear the political plan and not to
escape the transparency that we
have to face the
first question was the amount
needed to effectively deal
with this capacity to regain a
European well-being of  support our
economy throughout the next few months
of the next indicated the amount
needed
second question is how mobilis
bridge its means how affects all its
means as in the station in python these
means are well used and I will
tell you that there are a lot
of  he instruments that we can use for
solidarity
there are my eyes there is one that is very
natural very transparent that can be
very effective and the next mff is
the next European budget example for
which we are going to try at the next
council  European to see new
ammunition strategy sion liked to do
to try to as requested from the
commission that it can formulate
some proposals that take into
consideration this crisis with emotion
we are facing and the
different repercussions that are going to be
entailed
i  also to emphasize the fact
that this opera concert next week
is going well it's in a process I was reading
it's the fourth in just a few
weeks there will be others the goal
is to have validation  of one are two
political principles and to give
direction to give meaning to a
decision-making process which will
continue throughout the last
weeks and in the coming days we
will continue according to you have done a lot,
that is to say have a lot  of
political preparation at the level of
heads of state and government to
ensure that we can have a
comfort video next week which
is useful and which gives
impetus to be able to continue the
work towards this
recovery strategy and  of economic transformation
a dj well I'm mobilizing in the mellois
flex flexibilise drop in fine this gect
the photo credits john hall is closed
the date
the three weeks of another we
preach production also
precise news and very strong said how
dead stage  in stockholm new york in
budget elsewhere bemba just do it might
have many of you l'investment energy to
be necessary find yoruba jet d'eau de
windows rental is obvious ok five
matches
yes it happens especially effective actor
struggling iman bowie middle  y va de
soi
gwen know you go il ya le mike newton du
comic au quai de meantime let me go to
tomasz gop andy fantuz allgemeine
[Music]
zeitung the codex everything and it's an
opinion says this close
and this Kurd to one life  to be next time
machine moment date according to one of the
pastors all major magistrate
we import notified to open in shops
forms by washington in the
stingers two major queens might
be
after the ethnic and with you
control first put  in place so it's
not stop for god we do and black beats step
by step at project paris
ok thank you we had a small technical problem
all the people who had raised
their hands were erased I saw that of which
I would ask you to press  the
button
virginie sickly of the world I know that
you had asked to speak if you can
press the reset button and we
will not pass the floor these are the vagaries of the
new system
so in the meantime where they virginie you have
the floor by its amounts
yes everything  it really doesn't matter about the
same effect first the scalpel
a first question one of them a bit
of pain line it doesn't start until 2021
it's April 2001 we're going to need
money before January 2021 so you have
in between by the way assuming
that we find a solution
elsewhere is what in your
imagination will you imagine had
made a fault much larger
than the current size around 1%
since May we have seen  how the
member states tore each other's face at the
February council for anti forces
well here I had questions about the
green deal it it remains our priority
it remains an important priority we want to
guide one way or another
investments towards a city
but when we see your thoughts on the
work schedule of the commission
there are many elements that are
specific and without too much of your strategy
diedrick which includes being postponed
because you have no  choice and we
understand why so is
this talking about paradoxical and then I
also had a question about what you
concretely expect from the council of
April 23 to be that of waiting and
concrete things and bandas who wants to start
me perhaps on the next
multiannual budget the circumstances and it is
the coincidence of the calendar for the
truth leads us to be in the
situation where we have to take a
decision
thought so but also the
European parliament in connection with the next
more Rennes budget for the
next seven years and we must seize
this opportunity of the calendar in my opinion
by seven on the calendar
it allows to print la la la the
political choice that we want for the
next seven years at the same time by taking
into account  consideration
we have spoken a lot about the major impact, judging it
to be gigantic, of this sad situation and the
need that this imposes to adapt the
budgetary strategy of the European Union,
but it is also an opportunity to transcribe
in this next European budget
this digital priority and  green deal which
can be pillars for the
transformation and for the
economic recovery which we need
a fortiori after this crisis we are
convinced that this crisis does not make
the climate issue does not erase
the digital issue but on the contrary this
crisis shows that we must use these
two levers the strongest
even faster to succeed in this transformation
to this recovery and 15 we need
first point second element poses a
very concrete question on how do
we manage financially the next few
months rue  the first decisions have been
taken which have an impact on the
liquidity of many companies of
the victim which in europe it is a good
thing in the debate that we have had
and lover we will also see if we must
consider mechanisms  which will make it possible
in the coming months to have
additional funding for
additional to cope with the fact
of having, for example, activate the
lost sticks of one of the capacities for
member states to provide very direct support
very immediately two sectors are
affected
the worker  which are
also affected or support
health care systems and finally for
the third point which is latent for
the next European Council I
repeat it will be our fourth
European Council in a few weeks
and everyone knows European Council has
issued very  strong they
had an impact
we recognize at the start of the crisis
and at the start of the first
national measures of restrictions and
containment we found that it took
a few days and the commission and yours
truly we worked
so that we could cooperate  better on the
issue of borders, for example,
working better to coordinate
a certain number of joint actions
I expect and we expect the next
concert next week to
continue to amplify this
operational return this cooperation this
ordination for which we give
to the states mans of the proposals of the
recommendations of the 10 dances which are
imbued with common sense of the rods ensure
that we are more successful
as much as possible in this
progressive exit from the restriction measures
which have been decided and we are
also waiting  on the four points that I
mentioned in the introduction that there
is a political strategy for
battles political strategy and
guidelines that they be given so
that we continue with the member states
with the commission with their group  with
the European investment bank
with all of the players attracted in
the same direction with the same approach
with the same strategy
and I actually claim this
idea that this
economic recovery transformation plan that I call for
it must  being of the marshall plan type by
its ambition and by the major leverage effect
that it must represent in order to
succeed as quickly as possible has brought back
a capacity for the european union
to have an internal market that not
simply repairs but functions
better more  strongly even than before the
crisis and which is even more so in
capacity to support
economic activities and whose capacity for
social cohesion in all European countries
[Music]
fqu sinbad I have all many others  where
normal and low date
the mechanism and the notes we accept
an original instrument convergence it
[Music]
because it is not prosperity is validated
pending style between 629 context
[Music]
politico necessity we must price
because klein chain globo but non stop
taiwo who bongo and especially financial
forecasts of our exact global shareholding
in europe in your eyes wide open
university of course
photo suzanne in rome expression unknowns
[Music]
who had bounced back second home
the baby just want to be about the next
a youpine budget  budget is very soon
to fu sold out there is value from
yoplait
we need of power trio all say they are betrayed
showcases of masters in design
from pindi festivities addresses the define
everything this weekend youth in a day to die
from federici petite  routine of a
portfolio of funds in the hands of
stephen keith event of this type and
chivalry essentials matters well off
of solidarity is in the values ​​of a
little sister is stubborn and takes ten goals we
of all
we need to use and we have already  you
some very important all this weight of
history this carries economy and with an
open lips it continues
discussion hall sweeney tour fpt repeat again
for little bit more clarity addresses 10th
mind of the bill of the crisis and the
moment yes a destiny  to be we can make
some provisions this vote
win it may be my instrument of all the
thefts all kinds challenge for 2009
two main currencies of our star
right to prove one of 50 points
heavy debt yesterday and
beast we do you know in europe
invida  bac 5 and the dates here 10 6 x 2
go in pick-up mask indh and some think
you think you be your lover given my
priority
marc coma he would be in love mask quoted
mails surfing to reduce the speed of and
a faction important measures  and
internet
duchesneau contained she said to dom
easy to follow my god of course but my
daughter told me yes the move to all in
the city roque santa maria regulate
the agricultural supply which hides a
wild group a complete of  the
large distribution
naf naf fort dit niet of the masses nam ang
is the exact opposite more functional
of the web and music
we know that you have to buy
sean price added another element which
seems important to us from many countries
and replace is a  good thing have taken
the initiative to encourage the increase in
production in the European countries of the
equipment that we need and we must
actually encourage
more product capacity more quickly in the
European countries to have a capacity
to be much less dependent  that
we have been in a lot of
european countries the last weeks
of equipment that is produced
outside the european union also
a subject i think we will have to take into
consideration if we want a
resilient dress and a europe  able to
really take his destiny in hand
without being dependent on the outside world
very well thank you
we will take one last
question from tania raise me this case tania
and daughter claude rich media of the vote
yes we you hear me yes absolutely
yes yes then  a question on quora from the
western balkans if you allow me
so i am from the macedonian national news agency
the dishes were taken in several
countries in the western balkans
robbie mcewen from northern montenegro was
very criticized by civil society
in particular because they are
extremely hard cd cdc quarantine
extraordinary measures where people
have to stay
home for 72 hours
sometimes there is a lot of criticism
about the anti
democratic effects especially in serbia
elections have been suspended and
its interests so i would have liked
to know if this is something that
the council looks at as much as I observe do
you have a comment on it thank you
I want to tell you that with
the western balkans we are in
very close contact, especially as
decisions have been taken  a few
weeks ago which aims to initiate
negotiation processes with in connection
with joining the european union
this is the case for hamasyan from the north and
albania i had the opportunity
last week  to speak for
example with the president of
north macedonia for the elections for example
we are perfectly informed and
we understand that the various
political parties in north macedonia
supported majority-opposition this
idea of ​​postponing the elections he had
also observed that  even inside
the european union
the coronavirus has had an impact on
elections it was the present case
municipal in france you are right but it
is certain that our relationship to this
region and to all of these countries
very clear political message our
habits we have systematically it is the
concern for the rule of law for
the respect of the principles and freedoms
that we want to promote and it is
moreover an important part that
occupied our action when it  has been
in recent weeks in recent months
to be in talks with cp with this
region of the world and by one we
also want within the framework of the thoronet virus for
the external action which is carried out to be
in close support towards this region of the
world  we also want to mobilize
support for economic development
in this region but in connection with
reforms which must continue and which
must be intensified
we also want to encourage the
reduction of disputes in this region
of the world, which was the case with
the agreement  press not for example which is
a good example in order to negotiate to
reduce tensions in the region and
finally it is planned to have
knocked out in the next few weeks
probably by videoconference we
still have to decide in connection with the
Croatian presidency of the European union
in order to be able to give impetus
in terms of the political cooperation process
but also in order to see
how we can continue with a
partnership in the fight against the role of the
coronavirus so we are going if you can
give me the floor again thank you we are going to
come back to a point  which had been
raised by virginie du monde
concerning the dichotomy between 2020 and
2021 the possibility of intervening god
from 2011 president not be used to be
protest on the same date and
buildings become quickly then next
between one and the roof of them fff
very  well thank you very much we are
now coming to the end of this
press conference as a reminder you will be able to
review all the